the Joe Rogan experience Joe they didn't
even know FDR was crippled that's right
FDR was crippled yeah see huh they
didn't know he would literally hold
himself up at the podium I think he got
polio or some [ __ ] right so he was
paraplegic right and but the press
respected his role as president and they
respected his privacy I mean he had side
[ __ ] he had all this [ __ ] going on
and he was just stand up at the podium
holding himself up whenever you were
talking everything else besides that
they kind of roll him around but the
people didn't know cuz there wasn't this
access oh I want us to get back to lying
each other cuz think about it used to be
a time where you didn't know what
somebody's religion was we didn't know
what somebody's political views were
like you didn't like nobody knew like
you just went you presented and you went
the [ __ ] home I think we need to get
back to that well I think it's too much
[ __ ] so every so small truth
get back in the closet not just with
your - it's just what else get back to
[ __ ] me just get back to [ __ ] in
each other because guess what remember I
used to say you don't want the truth cuz
you can't handle the truth
that dis era the world cannot handle
truth that's why anyone tell us about
UFOs what we think is happening with
UFOs they won't tell if that UFOs exist
because if they told us that UFOs exist
[ __ ] would probably go crazy
when the reality is we really probably
need to know UFOs exist because it would
humble the [ __ ] out of everyone well
that's the only time we get along right
like in every movie right the only time
Russia and China and America get on a
conference call is when bro movies
aliens are coming up the movies Ronald
Reagan said that in a speech in the 80s
Ronald Reagan told Mikhail Gorbachev why
to [ __ ] a we beefin cuz one day we might
be we might have an extraterrestrial
threat and then we got to come together
and everybody was like what the [ __ ] is
Ronald Reagan talking about look quickly
we would put aside our differences were
a threat face face within a threat from
an alien world and everybody was like
what does he know yeah I would respect
I'm gonna find out tonight I would
respect your prejudice if aliens came
and you still had Helen or whatever the
[ __ ] you still hated like he was still
racist you were still homophobic if you
were still transposing after
get pregnant
hold on et me oh my god respect to [ __ ]
okay
alright I tell you no it's true I
thought you know it's real that's what
long as it's real I really don't have no
choice but the reason I keep Johnny
where I think we're getting to the end
of outrage nobody's culture I think
she's almost over we had we put on a
clip this last week of there was his kid
in the front row in a wheelchair
heckling that was hilarious and we went
back and forth and initially I put it
out like a [ __ ] what's gonna happen am I
gonna have these like you know people
rollin up to my shows and like [ __ ]
pull you have it really well
he was also a special kid yeah he had
something you know people have it your
River around people and they just have a
[ __ ] yeah like they have a clique
you know who has it Ari ari Ari Shaffir
he has this [ __ ] I don't there's
something I just when I'm around I just
like him yeah I just kind of wanted to
tell me his opinions on [ __ ] yeah how'd
you feel about carpets and he'll just
[ __ ] tell you how they I'm dumb
whatever so it's like he just had this
thing needs such positive energy and I'm
making fun of a guy from [ __ ] being
in a wheelchair and he's making fun of
me for having a shitty upper body and
like literally I go to him I was like I
said you know your upper body's pretty
good and he goes what's your Excuse like
quick and we had this moment and no
backlash yeah the thing was cool no
backlash shouldn't matter except for the
guy in the wheelchair right if everybody
else is like wow a lot of [ __ ] are you
picking on him if the guy in the
wheelchair don't care and the guy in the
wheelchair is going back and forth what
a [ __ ] you just never people that have
it never always parents of people that
have things like when there was this
person as a seizure in one of my videos
everybody who had seizures was cool with
it it was always a parent of a kid who
had a seizure who was like my son
suffers from how dare you a clip up like
that so it's always a fence on behalf of
because I really think that people who
suffer for things they went through way
harder things in a joke yeah and they
actually like that they're being spoken
to as a regular person in the audience
not babied like every other part of
their life where can I get the door for
you can I get it's like they all right
for the first time I'm in it